march 22 a black day for
belgium a black day for europe
insidious murderers carried out a
horrific series of terror in brussels
the cynical calculation of such assassins
is to frighten all of brussels all of belgium all of
europe so that the
fear and us conquer our hearts
that is why we must  remain level-headed
don't put every muslim under
general suspicion i equate islam
with the primitive islamism of the murderers
we mustn't delude ourselves beforehand
this terrorist is global and
by the way most of the victims of
this terror are muslim this terrorist
a global challenge and we
won't tackle them individually
national measures can answer
the fight against terrorism requires
that we all stand together in europe
together and in the world